George Steinbrenner was arguably the
most impactful owner to come through
baseball he built the Yankees into the
financial Behemoth they are today the
most valuable team in baseball valued at
6 billion according to our estimates he
led them the seven World Series
countless Marquee free agent signings
Steinbrenner never hesitated to bring
stars to the Bronx from Reggie Jackson
to Alex Rodriguez he always pushed to
keep the Yankees competitive and his win
at all cost mentality could be
detrimental at times especially how he
was perceived in the public eye but
ultimately he put a winner on the field
many times on Seinfeld we quit a glimpse
of what was supposed to be the back of
George steinburner's head he was
parodied on the popular sitcom and it
was an enjoyable exaggeration that
reflected how he was this Larger than
Life Persona I remember the first time
the character appears is when George
Costanza is following the opposite of
his instincts and interviewing for a job
with the Yankees and he runs in the
Steinbrenner and ends up insulting him
and the line is something like hire this
man foreign and I think that's just
representative of how kind of
temperamental Steinbrenner was and how
fiery he was and just how much of a
larger than life Persona he had become
he was passionate but he was also
erratic you know you look back at some
of the things that happened during his
tenure he hired and refired manager
Billy Martin several times he went
through a number of publicists during
the early years of his tenure and also
he had some more complicated issues in
his regime he was kicked out of baseball
twice the first for making illegal
campaign contributions which I should
say that he was later pardoned for but
also he later made Shady business
dealings in the 90s that resulted in
another Breakaway from the game well
more so his day-to-day management of the
team when George passed away in 2010 he
was survived by his wife and his four
children Hal Hank Jessica and Jennifer
his wife later passed away but
coincidentally he died in a year where
there was no estate tax so if he had
passed away months later and the new
rate of 55 had kicked in which it did in
January of 2011 his heirs could have
been on the hook for something like 600
million in the time since George's death
the Yankees have grown tremendously in
value from 1.6 billion in 2010 to 6
billion today that's been the primary
driver of growth for this family's
fortune and we estimate that each of
George's kids got an equal share
Hank unfortunately George's eldest son
died in 2020 so it's unclear what
happened to his share of the fortune but
we estimate that his three surviving
kids Hal Jessica and Jennifer based on
their controlling interests in Yankee
Global Enterprises which is the holding
company of the Yankees makes them all
billionaires Under the Umbrella of
Yankee Global Enterprises the holding
company that controls the Yankees there
are several other businesses the
Steinbrenner family has pieces of one is
the Yes Network which is the network
that George actually came together with
the Nets and created to broadcast Yankee
games regionally there's also New York
City FC the major league soccer club
that plays in Yankee Stadium as well as
Legends Hospitality a joint venture that
Steinbrenner came together with Dallas
Cowboys owner Jerry Jones to form in
2008 and then more recently Yankee
Global Enterprises took part in Redbird
capital's acquisition of Italian soccer
club AC Milan were reported 1.28 billion
in terms of how the heirs compared
George's oversight the Yankees it's
definitely a more quiet and tranquil
regime
how is the guy who runs the team now and
he's not necessarily the outspoken
person that his father was or even that
his older brother Hank was
but that doesn't mean they've lost their
reputation for spending in 2017 they
traded for John Carlos Stanton to Star
outfielder who had signed a 13-year 325
million dollar contract with the Marlins
two years later they went out and
shelled out another 324 million signing
Garrett Cole to a nine-year deal the
most ever for a major league pitcher
success is kind of lagged though for the
franchise they're in the midst of a
World Series drought over the last 13
years the last time they won was 2009
when George was still alive and they
haven't been back to the fall classic
since
so you could say that the Yankees
haven't achieved what they've wanted to
in that time but also they've been
competitive on the field nearly every
year they were back in it winning 99
games this year so it depends how you
define success but the Yankee brand
demands success
and not reaching the World Series
especially over the last few years is
something that definitely weighs heavily
on the franchise